tercer atentado terrorista en israel en
tan solo una semana tras los ataques con
cuchillo y arma de fuego en ver chivas y
jáder a la periferia de tel aviv ha sido
el escenario de un nuevo tiroteo con
cinco víctimas mortales en esta ocasión
un motorista armado de un fusil m-16 fue
quien disparó a transeúntes y vecinos de
las ciudades de vena y brack y ramat gan
dicho atacante que también murió en la
escena fue identificado como un joven
palestino de cisjordania algo que éste
distingue de los otros autores árabes
israelíes simpatizantes del estado
islámico con un total de 11 personas
muertas en siete días los más
sangrientos desde el año 2006 el primer
ministro naftalí bennett declaró que
israel se enfrenta a una ola mortal de
terrorismo árabe contra la cual prometió
luchar con mano de hierro un mensaje que
está lejos de calmar las tensiones en
vísperas de abril mes que ya inquietaba
por la coincidencia del ramadán la
semana santa cristiana y la pascua judía
muestra del temor a una nueva espiral de
violencia son las reacciones a este
atentado por ejemplo celebrado por hamas
y la jihad islámica a la vez que
repudiado por los ultraortodoxos de pene
y vrac al grito de muerte a los árabes
en medio en un gesto poco común el
presidente palestino mahmud abás condenó
la matanza diciendo que conduce a un
deterioro de la situación ante este
escenario la policía israelí ya ha
decretado el nivel de alerta máximo que
se suma a recientes redadas en barrios
árabes y ensayos de alarmas antiaéreas
por su parte benet liderará este
miércoles un gabinete de seguridad en el
que revisará el actual plan de
contención